vinassan soir vous considère
effectivement comme une descendante de
george-sand en r vous êtes retrouvé
commandes me par son féminisme cet
engagement son besoin de liberté je
crois qui au delà de tout non et 15
qu'on peut donner à quelqu'un c'est vrai
que ce qui les différenciait j'ai
regardé votre votre petit reportage
ce qui les différencie est ce qui les
rapproche pas eu d'avancée là c'est
l'idée les l'idéal qu'ils ont en eux
l'amour qu'ils ont en eux mais aussi
musset écrivait il avait besoin de ses
états d'âme pour écrire et elle elle
elle écrivait quel que soit l'état de
son âme et ses deux formes de travail et
de pensée qui qui peuvent se rejoindre
mais au quotidien qui sont qui
s'affrontent à quand même c'est une
petite bourgeoise de province va quitter
son mari et elle est fascinée par ce
type totalement dépravés mais aussi
valoir avec atlantic bourgeoise de
province allait provincial mais elle a
été éduquée dans une atmosphère d'art
puisque sa grand mère c'était une adepte
de la peinture de la musique de la
littérature et de voltaire et george
sand elle était empreint de jean jacques
rousseau
donc elle avait la révolte en elle et sa
grand-mère et une révolte et aussi donc
elle est arrivée avec à paris c'est vrai
provincial mais à la fois avec une soif
de 2,2 de communication une soif de
réalisation d'elle-même et et elle est
venue avec beaucoup plus de force que
les parisiens eux mêmes dans l'
interprétation vous donner d'urgence en
moi parce que j'avais plutôt
l'impression souvenirs littérature c'est
une femme - - sensuellement 12 sont
incapables de quasiment de s'humilier
lorsque george sand 20 thalys a dit me
faire discret va se mouiller devant la
porte de ce que de son amant c'est
terrible vous vous avez effectivement
essayé de de lui donner une sensualité
plus forte je crois que dans l'amour
comme elle s'est engagée à ce moment là
on a plus de limites
elle a été au delà de ses limites et
c'est ce qui fait que c'est si touchant
de voir deux êtres se plonger à bras le
corps comme ça sans but et sans sens
sans avoir l'idée du lendemain et c'est
ce qui fait la force de la relation et
leur amour exceptionnel les lettres
qu'ils échangent sont de toute beauté et
pas nous donner à nous aujourd'hui il
envie d'écrire
mais c'est toute beauté mais c'est à
l'unisson de l'extrême violence qu'il ya
quelquefois entre eux il ya des scènes
terribles d'entre vous oui ce sont les
idéalistes qui confronté à un quotidien
et c'est vrai qu'entre le lard et à la
réalité on a des difficultés on ad on a
des douleurs des souffrances est ce que
vous pensez qu'il ya un moment de
jalousie de créateurs entre est-ce que
musset va être flamboyant et j'en
ressens tu veux faire je crois 80 romans
n'aura pas cette espèce de flamboyance
dans l'assiette des premières femmes à
travailler avec la gagner sa vie avec
avec l'art d'écrire
mills avait pas besoin d'argent il avait
la famille derrière et c'est vrai que
c'est une conception différente
george-sand ne réalisez pas ses romans
il fallait aller vite gagner le plus
vite possible de l'argent pour pour
tenir une maison des enfants et puis
être généreuse comme l'a été mais il
avait une conception de travail
différente mais il
il n'empêche que les lettres d'un
voyageur histoire de ma vie
journal intime des corps et celle la
correspondance de george-sand sont
uniques et sont des chefs-d'oeuvre en
soit c'est vrai que musset par les
pièces de théâtre on donne une pâle avec
l'amour lorraine nature évidemment
confirme d'un enfant du siècle sont des
livres de aussi de passion et de 2 sur
la semaine donc c'est qu'ils marquent
bien l'actualité de ce siècle là mais en
même temps bon allez féministe diane
kurys disait précurseur féministe 20 ans
ne fait pas politique si elle a fait
beaucoup de politiques à la violence et
lui réclame l'union parce qu'elle n'a
pas été encore si au début de georges
sand elle est pas encore george sand est
en train de devenir on voit le démarrage
d'une femme parce qu'avant elle a été
elle était marié avec deux enfants elle
elle est partie et les trouver en
concession un compromis avec se marrer
venir six mois à paris et six mois en
province jusqu'au moment où elle a
commencé à travailler comme journaliste
elle est allée dans l'est dans les dents
les premières au théâtre et il fallait
être un homme près le premier théâtre
parce que c'est le film n'est pas cette
année le film c'est avant tout cette
passion amoureuse entre les deux c'est
avant tout cette bataille et c'est
d'autant plus surprenant c'est qu'on a
l'impression qu'une une féministe comme
elle je suis pas d'accord allez
maintenant elle a un besoin de liberté
on appelle aujourd'hui on peut l'appeler
féministe mais à l'époque c'était pas
une féministe c'est une femme qui avait
cabine révolte en aide qui avait besoin
de liberté dans un mariage confiné avec
le code napoléonien qui est pas qu est
pas mince et elle nous a c'est vrai
comme dit diane kurys ouvert une voie
royale pour pour le mail à l'idée du
droit de vote elle l'a eue à
voilà ce qui est quand même insensé
parce qu'on l'a vécu nous beaucoup plus
tard à chaque fois que vous êtes à
prêter des personnages vous garder
quelque chose de ces personnages ensuite
pour plus tard comme expérience à la
fois expérience personnelle vous permet
de découvrir qu'en donne on a toujours
quelque chose en retour
bizarrement et c'est vrai que la
préparation ça a été pour moi un
itinéraire amoureux est une passion
parce que dès qu'on lit sur des gens
passionnants on devient soi même
passionné et plus je la découvrais puis
j'avais envie de de la lyre et de
connaître qui elle était c'est un tout
allait tellement elle a été tellement
elle a été énormément de choses
donc bon c'est moi j'ai joué une partie
d'elle mais il ya encore beaucoup
beaucoup à découvrir
écoutez je dois vous dire qu'on était
passionné en tout comme moi j'ai été
passionné par la paire ce film il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sortent en même
temps il ya un bien un cd de musique
originale de louis basset fc les enfants
du siècle
il ya une exposition au musée de la vie
romantique puis un très beau livre des
éditions de la martinière sand et musset
j'ai tous les les lettres d'amour des
échanges qui sont de toute beauté qui
donne envie d'aimer en tout cas merci
beaucoup
nous arrivons à la fin de cette édition
je rappelle deux informations